less than a week after we were last here
and the covered situations a lot worse
the medics are working 20-hour days as
fast as they're expanding
their beds are being filled that has
happened since the last time you came
you know i had to open a brand new
unit which is next door another 35 beds
just because this is totally packed
and the doctors have noticed a worrying
trend many of the patients are people of
color
specifically african americans this my
home right now
latanya robinson's a nurse but was
working from home
she thinks she caught it from her son
who wasn't badly affected
it is serious it's not a hoax
it's not it doesn't have just one person
name
on it you know it's it's like a
a green slime floating in the air
and it could drop on anyone at any time
despite making up only 23 percent of
houston's population
the latest figures show african
americans account for around
66 percent of coveted deaths
jeffrey l boney beat the odds after nine
days in icu
people are just trying to figure it out
as they go
he insists america needs to face ugly
truths
there are two serious pandemics
that have played african-americans one
has been here since its inception and
that's racism
and uh and the other is is covet 19.
those two are vicious um
you know pandemics that are impacting
the lives
and the quality of life of african
americans in this country
the suffering by some is evident on
every street corner in parts of houston
people struggling to survive and just
get by
the coronavirus has smashed the economy
and those already at the bottom of the
pile
are the worst hit but to many here
racism has had a far more devastating
effect on their lives than the pandemic
we need change in the system we need
changing systems that's all we're asking
for
we're not asking we're not asking for
handouts we're not asking for sympathy
we just want to be equal
for these guys coronavirus is just one
of many challenges
well that's why black people is is less
moved by the
because bro and i ain't just telling my
black people as a whole i'm talking
about the slums people
in private and people going through we
got other people that we wrestling with
every day
his brother r.j maybach turned to boxing
to pull himself out of poverty
and keep himself out of trouble to the
immense pride of his elder siblings
my baby brother i think you're gonna be
the champ
this club was set up to help
disadvantaged youngsters
hasn't closed it nor has anyone been ill
you know if you're here you can't be out
committing no crime or doing something
trying out no business or even
out in harm's way you know what i'm
saying
pandemics brought hardship on millions
of families
the lines of people needing food parcels
include many african americans
and now it's rj's turn to help i come
from
you know obama so i know how ideas
i wish i had somebody like me you know
growing up
this is the town where george floyd grew
up and where there are constant
reminders of his killing and the
protests against racism which followed
now there's a growing demand for answers
about why there are such
racial health disparities amidst the
coronavirus pandemic
alex crawford sky news in houston texas